welcome to the show the car cast as I
call it now everybody thanks for
watching or listening now I want to talk
today about the worst the worst
pro-abortion argument and there are
great many to choose from so this is a
difficult it's it's pretty difficult to
decide there's a whole buffet a just
smorgasbord of terrible awful illogical
anti science arguments because every
pro-abortion argument is bad not just
bad morally but also just logically
unsound
but the worst one in my view is it's
it's the one that you've heard a million
times you hear all the time that the
baby isn't a baby it's a fetus it's a
clump of cells and it's not a real
person it is rather a potential person
the baby is a potential person now
you're not surprised of course that I
would cite this as the worst argument
because it's so common but you may not
expect why it is in my mind the worst
argument there's one thing in particular
that makes this line of reasoning really
really stupid and I want to explain what
that is but first of all we know and we
should establish again that it's a bad
argument first and foremost because it
just isn't true that's not what makes it
the worst argument because of course
every pro-abortion argument isn't true
but still we should stipulate that it
isn't at all true there's no such thing
as a merely potential human
either you either you're a human or
you're not okay either you're a person
or you're not a human as a human a
person is a person an unborn child has
the same inherent value as a born child
because it must logically scientifically
philosophically it must have the same
value do you know why because inherent
value is inherent and inherent means
belonging to a thing by its nature which
means that value if our value is
inherent as human beings which is what
most of us believe it's what our country
is built on the doctrine of human rights
is built on the notion that human rights
are inherent belonging to a thing by its
nature which means that if something has
inherent value its value cannot be lost
it cannot be gained it cannot it cannot
you cannot acquire it over time by
degrees it cannot be reliant on
circumstances it cannot be conditional
either you have inherent value or you
don't if our value is conditional which
is to say our value is conditional on
how useful our life is to those around
us how desirable our life is to those
around us whether it's our mother or
whoever else if that's the case then
human then that means that human value
is acquired over time by degrees it's
very conditional it's dependent on how
useful you are and so then there's
nothing necessarily wrong with slavery
or genocide or anything else
the only real argument against those
atrocities is that human beings have
inherent dignity if they don't well then
okay enslave away I guess the strong let
the strong survive dog-eat-dog world if
humans do not by nature possess an
infinite inherent value then it's
reasonable to claim that certain human
beings even of the born variety have
less accrued value than others
that would mean for instance if I'm
stronger and smarter than you I'm more
valuable
and it would be more of an injustice to
kill me than to kill you and probably I
should have the right to kill you if I
want because I'm the person with more
value and if I decided that your
existence was inconvenient to me well
then as the person with more value I
should be able to kill you also you know
to say that you have more value now than
you had in the womb is to say that you
are in essence is to say that you are
you now but you were not you in the womb
even though you were you
now if that's the case excuse me when
did you start being you if you did not
start being you at the moment you came
into physical existence if you if your
youness did not appear the same moment
that you appeared physically then when
did it appear and what what were you
before you were you this is how I try to
explain it to people this is you know
kind of the image I say okay so so so
just take yourself in your current form
okay
imagine yourself as you are right now
now we're whine the tape back to
yesterday was that still you did you
still have value okay now a year ago
now go back 10 years now go back 15 go
back to kindergarten go back to when you
were you know to your first birthday go
back to when you were six months old
keep following your own timeline all the
way back back back back back
we're whined the tape and then stop
there just right there at the moment
when you first emerged from the womb
into the world at that moment now that's
still you right that's you okay now just
rewind it one more second just one more
second is it still you
if that's not you and you did and you
didn't have value then what happened now
fast-forward a second just keep winding
fast-forward what's going on here in
this one second time what happened that
gave you value and eunice well of course
it had to be you even a second before a
second before you emerged it could have
been anyone else right you were you and
therefore you had value from the moment
that you first physically existed and if
you did not have value at that first
moment of existence then you don't have
value now again that's how inherent
value works
it must always belong to a thing in
order for it to be inherent value
didn't have it then you don't have it
now
but so we see that by removing value
from an unborn child we remove it from
all humanity because all of us wore it
one time and unborn human so we think
that we've taken it from everyone for
just from the babies we have taken it
from ourselves at the same time but
let's just okay so that's um that's why
the argument is wrong but that's not
even the point or it's not the only
point because here's the thing here's
the really incredible thing even if I
agreed that the fetus is merely a
potential human which I most definitely
emphatically irreversibly do not agree
but let's just say for the sake of
argument let's just say I did let's just
say I gave you that let's just say I
gave you the pro abort what if I just
said okay fine they're not people
they're not they're just potential
people they're not fully people fine
just for a moment let's just run with
that train of thought just for a second
okay
so they're it's it's not a person it's a
potential person wouldn't you still
treat this potential person like it's
the most valuable thing on the planet
wouldn't it still be a great injustice
and travesty to kill this life or this
potential life however you want to put
it
see that the pro-abortion position in
order to get to the pro-abortion
position you have to make two giant
impossible fantastic leaps and the first
leap is to declare that an unborn person
is not a person that is an impossible
leap to make scientifically the science
doesn't support it but even if I gave
you a trampoline and I said fine go
ahead and make the jump I'll set up like
a zip line so you can somehow make that
massive logical jump even if I did when
you land on the next platform you're
gonna find you have a whole new jump to
make because now you have to get from
here from it's not a person to let's
kill it
the two do not follow each other
logically they don't come hand-in-hand
just because I were diagram oment that
it's not a person doesn't mean I agree
we should kill it
so that's that's you've made it there
but you haven't made it all the way even
by proving that an unborn baby is not a
baby which you can't prove because it is
made but even in some science fiction
world where you did prove it you still
haven't proven that abortion is okay
here's an analogy it's kind of a crude
analogy it doesn't work on every level
but it works on one level at least when
we're dealing with this issue of
potential so what if you won what if you
won fifty million dollars in the lottery
and you had your fifty million dollar
lottery ticket let's pretend there's my
dry-cleaning receipt okay this is my
this is your fifty million dollar
lottery ticket and by the way can you
believe how expensive dry-cleaning is
these days I hadn't been to a dry
cleaner in a long time I just usually
iron my own clothes I didn't feel like
it it was like 50 bucks for just a few
anyway so you have your fifty million
dollar lottery ticket and you're you're
on your way to the lottery office to
cash it in and imagine that on the way I
run in and I snatch the lottery ticket
from you and then I just like eat it or
I set it on fire right in front of you
okay like the Joker in the Dark Knight
I'm just burning it right in front of
you now that ticket was not fifty
million dollars it's just a piece of
paper it's just a receipt there's a
million of them like this out there
that's all it is
it was moments away from being converted
into 50 million dollars but at the
moment it's just piece paper but how
would you react would you react as
though you just lost a piece of paper
would you react like I'd react if you
stole this from me be kind of
inconvenient I'd have to you know I'd
need to go and give him my name to pick
up my dry-cleaning but still would you
react like like like someone just took a
piece of paper or would you react as
though you had just lost fifty million
dollars I think we know
you would mourn the loss of that ticket
not as a ticket but as fifty million
dollars because you see whether the
ticket is 50 million dollars or is
merely the potentiality of 50 million
dollars that's basically irrelevant the
value is still the same and it would be
the same to you if you had the ticket it
would be the same in the eyes of the law
I imagine
or imagine if Majan I gave you some like
magical beam or something because that's
that's basically how Pro Awards View
unborn life they see it as a magical
beam like Jack and a beanstalk this
magical thing that just upon emerging
from the birth canal turns mysteriously
into a human so imagine that I actually
gave you a magical beam and I said okay
hold on to this and water it once a day
and in nine months it will turn into a
magic dragon that will grant wishes now
how would you treat that beam which
would you treat it as just any old
kidney bean throw it in a pot of chili
have it for lunch or would you treat it
like a magic dragon that could grant
wishes see this is the incredible thing
about the pro-abortion argument it fails
even on its own terms even if I agreed
with how they frame the argument which I
don't but even if I did I would still
see it as an act of just unspeakable
wickedness to murder this potential
human because even a potential child is
still worth more than every animal on
earth and it's more valuable than any
and than every object in the physical
universe and I don't even need to use
analogies of lottery tickets and magical
beans how about this instead
think about a bald eagle egg or an
endangered sea turtle egg now those are
both protected by the law it's illegal
to do any harm to an eagle egg or a sea
turtle egg all those in the scientific
mind of a leftist that Eagle egg is not
really an eagle it's just a potential
eagle the sea turtle egg not really a
sea turtle just a sea turtle just a
potential sea turtle yet if one if a
pro-abortion person stumbled upon me you
know if they were walking down the beach
and they came upon me and I'm just like
stomping a whole mound of sea of
endangered sea turtle eggs or if they
came into my kitchen and I said hey I'm
just cooking up some some bald eagle
omelets you want one they would faint
with just rage and then when they woke
up they probably stoned me to death and
then they'd call the police and I'd be
arrested while dead for doing this
horrible thing
so in the case of a sea turtle or an
eagle they have no problem seeing how
even a potential sea turtle is worth as
much as a sea turtle or a potential
eagle as much as an eagle yet with a
potential human they say it's worthless
it's trash throw it out doesn't make any
sense even on their own illogical terms
it is still illogical
so there you go all right we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody I'll
talk to you next time
you